great to have back here on the rich eyes
and show a man known as uncle Marshall
in my household and also is a pro
Football Hall of Famer everywhere on
planet Earth good to see you Marshall
Faulk good to be on your right reg you
bet it's great to have great to be on
your left let's put it that way
got Marshall back here someone who's
been your house for Thanksgiving almost
as much as I have except if Marshall
would return the Tupperware as something
all the time you didn't know the story
no oh man way back when Chris was not
the well-rounded man you see before you
okay
a man who cohabit eights with a with a a
steady okay I mean this man is not he's
not the guy that was your segment
producer for although you don't use a
mic in front of him he's gotta eats a
gun while working son runs up so we we
give him Suzie gives him some some
leftovers you know in a Tupperware and
the nice glass a nice glass one over
nice stuff so you know how it works it's
just like you know hey did uh did Chris
bring the Tupperware back at work no
would you mind asking him you know bring
Tupper up no problem
then comes the I'm just gonna text him
I'm gonna text him to get him to get
Tupperware back Suzie's firing off text
like are you getting tough red back or
not
whatever he then comes over to the house
six weeks later
well Christmastime right a month monthly
I don't play for weeks later with the
whole time in with gifts for the two
boys wrapped up handed them the top and
the bottom of the top where to the kids
that's good like a fisher-price
something
no nice mom's Tupperware nice that was
control on my children in my home where
my children come and play with their
toys would he at least had a real gift
for them no there was no real gift Wow
except his presence so let's get into
this thing right here we noticed on
James Slater's Instagram yeah she posted
something about the Ezekiel Elliott hold
out because she covers the Dallas
Cowboys yeah you know for the NFL
Network yeah and then there was a
comment that you put on her Instagram
feed about wieder essentially why must
there be a reset at the runningback
market let's get right here why does the
RB market need a reset too many bum
cubies in the NFL atleast use the the
end of the test making undeserved or
unearned money you want to put a few
more mean rich I mean that was clear
right this kid is basically carried this
team the past three years and if you
just played a position a quarterback and
you just happen to be available your
next man up and I mean it's a really and
and there's a question like we need to
reset the market it's just weird to me
like the market need to be resetting our
inflation is inflation
you saw what Gurley got you saw what
levy I got the next year it goes up well
levy on and we had Stephen Jones on the
show his point is levy on did not
surpass Girly's contract so he reset the
market by signing where he is so that's
probably if I'm not mistaken where
they're showing up right now dollars and
cents was in between the bell and the
girly car okay
like I said I'm I am I am i warm um like
I said there's no reason a real
reset the market hmm
III mean let's just say let's just talk
about quarterbacks lips it's easy to see
what they're saying about the running
man when Kirk Cousins was up for a deal
nobody talked about resetting the market
when Garoppolo who hadn't played a whole
season yet nobody talked about resetting
the market I
it's just the knick phone no money
nobody talked about Nick phones when
wince got his deal market didn't need to
be reset why are we talking about
resetting a market on the player now
i'ma tell you this rich and I metritis
it is as delicate as possible I can't
wait to see if they're going to try to
reset the market on dak Prescott or is
he just next man up that's an excellent
question
yep I think they're they're going to try
and reset the market on dak Prescott and
I yeah that's why dak has yet to be
signed right now I don't think that dak
Prescott will come out with a contract
that makes him either
annually or total war guaranteed
why the highest-paid quarterback it's
the difference between he and went are
you are you going in the direction where
I think you're going I'm not going
anywhere else is asking you a question
rich well I think again dak has proven
that he deserves a great contract I
don't know we call it the bag well the
bag so where do you stand on dak then I
think that deserves his buddies you
think Jack deserves the the to be paid
the highest paid quarterback in the NFL
what he's the nights just next man that
rich I'm not now I know that you have an
issue with the way that the that you're
obviously pointing out the running back
and the quarterback markets are treated
completely separately and we can return
to that argument in a second but knowing
the quarterback situation in terms of
being paid as you pointed out is he is
he one of the bum quarterbacks that
you're talking about he will be once
they give him that kind of money based
on
his work he'll be a bum he'll be one of
them yeah
who's the non bum quarterback should
Rodgers Brees Brady Phillip Phillip
these guys I think he's worried he's
going through his last year Russell
listen I love Phillip and here's the
thing you have to decide with the
quarterback are you trying to sell
tickets because you have a quarterback
that gives you a chance or you know that
this quarterback he's had meaning your
chances to get you there but he can't
get you to or you don't want to start
from the beginning again like Arizona's
doing this year like the Giants might
have to do this year if he lies stumbles
and and Daniel gets in there or he gets
hurt or the Washington Redskins are
doing right now or like last year what
the Cardinals did with Josh Rosen and
then in restarted again go back into
that situation at some point maybe just
maybe I haven't heard somebody thinks
this will happen at some point an owner
in the situation that say Jerry Jones is
right now with dak we'll just say go
ahead and walk
yeah I'm not paying you what is
supposedly the next man up market value
deal not doing it I'd rather just go
back in the draft and I'll take somebody
and take my chance in a second and
third-round pick and develop that kid I
start heading yet I have yet to see a
team blink and say no we're not paying
you we're just gonna let you go other
than the Redskins with Kirk Cousins yes
and after they franchise tagged him
twice they just saying it they made a
very good decision when you think about
it he went to a better team who had a
less of a quarterback and took them
lower Pro Football Hall of Famer
Marshall Faulk here on the Rich Eisen
show now the running back market is
treated differently because can't you
draft somebody
at third fourth round and get somebody
yes in years one two and three to just
be dominant I mean yeah so you can't do
what you can't do it the quarterback
position
pretty much I believe that's wrong you
do I believe that's wrong why is the
greatest quarterback to ever play this
game will be a guy who was missed upon
on multiple rounds by a hundred and
ninety eight picks mm-hmm oh yes you can
if you do your homework
I mean Garoppolo was missed upon just
just look at it but but Brett and it did
Brady was in you did win in year two
that's a rarity though right isn't that
isn't that the isn't that the exception
to the rule here that's what I'm saying
is that running backs can come off a
campus out of Tennessee like Alvin
Kamara and be dominant and maybe even be
an offensive rookie of the year if not
potential MVP candidate in the way a
rookie quarterback can't be but if you
if you look at I must say yesterday
because obviously sometimes things are
missed the intangibles with the running
back you don't really know as a defense
the line is it this or is it that you
you really don't know you take you take
TD you know people didn't know that TD
was that that he could do what he did
but they didn't look at him at did they
didn't really evaluate him right coming
out of Georgia you know cuz he started
off at Long Beach State he transferred
and things didn't go the right way or or
Kamara
he had some issues before he got in a
position that's why fell to the third
round exactly so things happen things
that or you play at a small school and
they say well the competition is that
what it is are you talking about
yourself or no no no I was number two I
was second pick over exactly
Indianapolis it's basically you told the
Bengals a good decision guys if I say
this rich if taking a risk if you have
to draft the position early the position
where where guys have failed the most is
quarterback I mean we have a lot of
quarterbacks in his Lee who was drafted
high
made a lot of money and they can't win a
playoff game that's true they're still
that haven't won a playoff game and
they've been paid paid I'm talking bags
and bags there Stafford one of those bum
quarterbacks why would you call Stafford
a bump I don't know I'm CUBAN just
throwing I wouldn't consider him as such
I'm just wondering what you would
consider I would you would consider him
yeah and guess where he's gonna get a
chance to get another contract and
continue on and they're not gonna hit
the reset button well there is a report
from Edward or about Ezekiel Elliott
really let's take a break we'll come
back hold on it to put you can put it
down we're gonna take a break and come
back Marshall Faulk I want to hit you on
what you're willing to tell me about
Zeke okay okay yeah cuz I mean you're
you're locked in you couldn't be more
locked in right okay okay
you won't even confirm that you're
locked in here's what I will confirm
Marshall Faulk is locked in for the rest
of the hour here on the rich Eisen ship
can you at least confirm that I am
confronted you front Marshall Faulk is
confirmed I want to know about Zeke
Elliott and I need to know if I'm eating
a hat
I can't even read anything off of him
right now his reaction that you weren't
even looking up Chris well I'm looking
how much Matt Stafford's made in his NFL
career all right all that we come back
here with Pro Football Hall of Famer
Marshall Faulk we're on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app